c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale
des mobilités et de l'accessibilité
c'est l'occasion de vérifier sur le
terrain si la réglementation française
est bien appliquée et les bâtiments
recevant du public sont ils tous
accessibles aux fauteuils roulants
elle les trottoirs permet-il à une
poussette ou à une personne en fauteuil
de circuler sans danger la réponse à
tour avec ce test grandeur nature
réalisée par paul boyer grigori et david
sont en fauteuil roulant depuis
l'enfance pour eux allait acheter le
pain ou se rendre chez un ami peut
rapidement devenir un véritable calvaire
chaussées déformées voitures garées sur
les passages piétons
autant d'obstacles qui peuvent faire de
leur quotidien un enfer on se retrouve
autour
renault se trouve que vous mettez vous à
la place aux gens en fauteuil
quand les trottoirs sont inaccessibles
pas d'autre solution que de circuler sur
la route pour david
c'est toute la question de l'urbanisme
qui est à revoir et pas question de
laisser les personnes non valides sur la
touche
on essaiera un problème ou l'handicap et
la personne valide ya il dit c'est une
différence
sauf que le combat de
de cette semaine c'est justement de dire
qu'il n'ya pas différente pour
l'association apf france handicap cette
semaine des mobilités est l'occasion de
rappeler la nécessité des décisions
politiques pour que l'accessibilité
devienne un combat général sans une
prise en compte réelle des politiques
nous restons comme en coin s'est isolé
tout simplement parce qu'il n'ya pas eu
l'effort de fait pour un lieu précis
dans des circonstances précises
quand je dis ça c'est la rue c'est le
transport c'est l'habitat c'est la crise
imité au magasin de leur côté david et
grigori garde le sourire et compte bien
continuer à sensibiliser l'opinion
publique car rendre accessible l'espace
public c'est aussi faciliter la vie des
personnes âgées et des non valide